I think it's in mourning and melancholia
that Freud said something about
melancholic s' having a unique
perspective on civilization but at what
cost you know and that's sort of my
experience too that the unhappier parts
of my career enabled me to say the more
trenchant things perhaps but I'm not
satisfied with the sort of psychic
economics of that because if I'm not
happy enough to finish the book or too
miserable to be able to want to do my
job
it doesn't matter what truth is I'm
capable of scaring up in my brain at
that time I don't know why it is exactly
that creativity and depression go hand
in hand but I'm sort of happy that they
do in so far as that there has to be
someone who's able to stand enough
outside of civilization to comment on it
maybe it's just a kind of exile you know
when when Joyce says silence exile and
cunning are the ways to become a great
artist and importer of the artist as a
young man I take the exile part to heart
you need to be able to sit outside a
little bit to look clearly at what's
happening but that also presupposes that
you're not in society and thus not part
of its happy throngs
I was talking to Mary gates kil about
this the novelist Mary gates kill and we
were particularly discussing the
suppression of libido in contemporary
antidepressant medication and her theory
was that you had to be sad a little bit
in order to have great sex so the two go
hand-in-hand as you suppress the sadness
you also suppress sexual impulse in some
way and you sort of go contentedly along
in life incapable incapable of the most
passionate moments you know and it's
possible that something similar happens
to to art if you sort of have everybody
operating at this contented mean you
don't enable the sorts of outrage or the
kinds of passionate enthusiasm that make
important art happen I mean I I suspect
I've never been on Prozac or any of
those kinds of medications but I suspect
that people who are who are still enjoy
great art and are perfectly capable of
liking a great novel no matter how
challenging it is you know and they
would say that that's not that their
medication is not interruptive of that
experience but then how does it work for
the people who make it you know David
Wallace is perhaps an example you know I
think his depression enabled him to be
the great artist that he was it also was
perhaps the thing that killed him you
know but it's also true that he was
unable to finish a novel after Infinite
Jest and he was on medication for a
while so who knows maybe there's some
connection there